i welcome everyone we would be starting
in more 12 minutes at the scheduled time
thank you for joining
i welcome those who have just joined we
would be uh beginning the webinar in
most seven minutes at the scheduled time
meanwhile it would be
nice if you all could introduce yourself
in the chat box maybe you can tell your
name and also here from which
degree or batch
hello everyone i welcome you all to the
webinar on winter research fellowship
program
this research fellowship program has
been designed to help young researchers
and students take advantage of the
bioinformatics resources for analysis of
complex high throughput life science
data and become versed in bioinformatics
this program offers you to participate
in real and cutting-edge bioinformatics
research and to be a part of renowned
bioinformatics community
omics logic is an international program
that is running in five different
regions with over 15 000 users around
the world and due to this fast growth
our team is working with local and
regional coordinators that are helping
refine the program logistics and
leverage our online training resources
adapting them to the needs of students
and researchers around the world
our mixed logic programs follow a
project based learning approach using
research grade tools to analyze data
from top peer reviewed journals and also
the training has been completed by over
10 000 participants from 162 countries
in over 300 workshops for six different
specialization tracks being oncology
infectious diseases precision medicine
neuroscience data science for biomedical
data and comprehensive training on omics
data analysis
our training is designed to allow
participants to apply methods to curated
and new data sets and develop
independent projects that showcase what
has been learned in the context of a
personal portfolio of projects as a
result anyone starting on this journey
in bioinformatics can start developing a
project of their own
in fact we have already worked with many
students who have completed this kind of
training and developed interesting
research projects that one awards and
got published in peer-reviewed journals
as well
in this session you will hear about some
of the critical points that makes the
project ready for a peer review we will
discuss the structure of the program and
also here about network of campuses
expert mentors and we will also hear
updates from students and mentors who
are supposed to complete the projects
and learn about various resources that
are covered in the program
the resources that are covered in the
program includes the omixlogic courses
on bioinformatics precision medicine
multi-omics including genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and
epigenomics as well data science that
includes bioinformatics using r and
python and the structural aspects of
biology that is chem informatics
as a part of the program you would also
get the access to the example projects
from different fields which you could
learn from and replicate for your own
research work
you can also explore various projects by
our research fellows in various fields
including neurosciences genomics
transcriptomics infectious diseases etc
now i would like to pass on the stage to
our mentors for further discussion about
the program and at first i would like to
invite elia broski ceo pine biotes
to uh talk more about the structure of
the program and why is it really
important for you all to work on a
research project over to uae
thank you very much
so
um
it's exciting to see many of you join
today and i think that many of you are
probably wondering
what makes this program different or
special
in the
available programs online where you can
learn about bioinformatics you can learn
about data science
the reason why we developed this program
is specifically to go beyond training
and offer an opportunity to participate
in meaningful research now in today's
session we're going to address many of
the challenges that are associated with
research projects especially getting
those research projects completed in a
short amount of time because typically
they do take years
at the minimum
several months and so what i want to
talk to you today about
are some of the critical things that
we've
distilled into this online program
and introduce you to some of the mentors
to talk about some of the specific
project examples but before we do that
let me briefly address some of these
critical points
one of the things that we've realized is
that when people join our different
training programs
their background in life sciences might
prevent them from
really getting deeper into
bioinformatics methods allowing them to
superficially know the terminology but
not really know how to apply it
practically
so i
think that you know many of you will
discover that some of the training
materials that we've designed are
specifically
useful for those that come from a life
science background without a lot of
technical engineering
skills and then you will be able to
really appreciate both the logic of the
analysis and technically how to become
independent and efficient in
bioinformatics analysis methods
the second area where many students
have faced a challenge is finding an
impactful research topic
and to find that impactful and
meaningful topic
we've addressed this through two
different
approaches the first one is literature
review how to perform literature review
so that you can find the specific gaps
in research and opportunities for you to
do something new and different and at
the same time find data that you can
find answers for that question that
research question so it's developing the
research question finding the data we
review many data sets with our community
to provide you with a curated start so
that you can start investigating a topic
using a curated data set and then find
opportunities to innovate and ask
questions of these data sets including
introducing you to the
approach of finding data sets online
and then finally the third topic is how
to know that what you have developed is
a meaningful project not just for the
student community but also for the
scientific community and that's why we
have developed a network of mentors that
come from a research as well as industry
background that are able to provide you
with
critical feedback so that your project
becomes more impactful and refine the
project or provide you with suggestions
on how to refine the project to make it
more impactful and uh essentially
providing with more visibility and
feedback
so before we continue
i want to show you how some of these
things are going to actually take place
and i want to introduce you to some of
the program resources really briefly and
to do that i want to
point you to
two servers and and two portals one of
them is going to be the server t-violin
for portal this is going to be a portal
uh that is
designed to provide you with an
opportunity to process big data
and also the learn
portal where you will find all of the
training resources so let's first go to
this portal the omixlogic portal and
thank you at jaspeed for sharing that
link and i'll also explain how those two
things are linked so if you go to this
portal link
you will find here i think a very clear
explanation of what this portal really
is the omixlogic portal is designed to
provide you with everything to get you
started and get you into these real
world practical challenges with big data
and you will find here tutorials project
examples on how to run various pipelines
and apply different analytical methods
you will find here different types of
research projects that you can get
started with in the fields of oncology
infectious diseases neuroscience
agriculture and others and you will also
find a meaningful application of your
logic how do you understand that you can
take raw data and get structured data
that you can analyze and supplement that
with training with
coding and machine learning and data
science and analytics
all of the necessary skills that will
make you independent and
self-sufficient as you go forward with
your projects so the first thing that
you want to do is you want to click
right here on login and i will give you
a couple of minutes to complete your
registration
so once you click on login you have the
option here to create an account
okay so i will wait a few minutes for
those of you that don't have an account
please take a few moments right now to
fill in your name your email and create
a password it's a free account you don't
have to pay for this but you will
immediately get access to some of the
free resources that are made available
and hopefully they will inspire you
to continue forward with a research
project using bioinformatics
so once you have completed your
registration please share
on the chat box the link to your profile
and i will explain briefly what you can
do with this profile okay so i will show
you my profile
okay once you log in you can click right
here and you will find your profile
open up and so
if you want to share your profile and
just go right here to the url on top
copy this url and you can share this
right here
with everyone in the chat box so please
let me know i'll give it a few minutes
so that
at least a few of you will be able to
complete your profile and share it with
us
for those of you that already have an
account
thank you aranza for those of you that
already have an account especially the
campus ambassadors that are here in this
session
please share your accounts as well
so we will take some account that is
complete so that we can show how a
completed profile looks
okay thank you
all right great so let's take just one
of these accounts as an example
uh here we have an account by subrajeet
who is already an expert how do we know
that he is an expert
he's an expert first of all because of
the activity that we can already see on
his profile so you can see that all of
your activity as you go through the
lessons as you try different projects as
you try different analysis techniques
are quantified and what that means is
that you get a number of points for
completing each step and that
immediately signals to the mentor
community that you have accomplished the
basic training and you're ready to get
started with your research project so
the way the research fellowship works is
it starts from this basic training
what is covered in the basic training so
importantly i think in today's world
when we speak about bioinformatics the
major focus is on big data
this big data comes in the form of
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics there are many different
types of omics and ultimately you have
to know how to process each individual
types of data and then integrate them
together to really have this systems
level view of what's happening in a
biological condition and so we've
designed these so that you have an
introduction and i will show you a
couple of courses that you can start
with for free so that you get into this
whole field of omnics data
then you go through this basic training
and then you get into introduced to the
data science curriculum in r and python
so i will briefly show you a couple
examples and this is just to get you
started
so again as you can see this profile it
is complete with activity i can see
which courses super g has completed and
i can also see that he has earned
certificates and those certificates are
going to stay with you unless the course
has been updated and when it's updated
your certificate will be
taken away so that you can complete the
remaining lessons and then get the
certificate back and that way we know
that you're staying up to date on some
of these important topics
in addition to that you can participate
in programs and today we're speaking
about the research fellowship program
but also we have many others that are
led by mentors who are experts in the
field and you will also be able to
develop a project so
as we go through one of the requirements
that this program has is so that you
complete your basic training now where
would you start your basic training
here on the courses tab right here in
the menu
you can find a lot of courses that as
you work through some of the material
will get a personalized suggestion for
your profile so you can see that for me
i have some suggestions on single cell
transcriptomics machine learning ebola
virus etc and that's because of my
interests
but here below i have a list of
recommended and highly uh active courses
as well as some of the as well as some
of the
collections of courses that you can find
right here and one of the collections is
called getting started so i can just
click right here on getting started and
see what's included the course that we
recommend for all of you to start with
is a course called bytes and molecules
the course
explains many of the basic terms
[Music]
sorry
a lot of the basic terms that you need
to know to get into this field and it is
uh
using you know language that anyone can
understand both with
and without
the kind of bioinformatics background
and it covers important topics that you
will want to understand before you
really get into
a lot of the material that is related to
research using bioinformatics so that's
just where you would want to start with
so after you complete
enough material to generate 10 000
points what will be made available
is right here
under projects you will be able to start
a new project and that is essentially
what this program is all about so this
program is going to be
focused on getting beyond the training
after you've completed the 10 000 points
and into a research topic now one of the
immediate challenges with that is how do
you process this huge amount of data
that oftentimes is beyond several
gigabytes or even terabytes of data that
you have to download on your computer
and so for that we specifically designed
a big data analysis platform that will
cover many of the typical processing
steps that reduce the amount of data
from gigabytes and terabytes to just
megabytes which is possible to analyze
either on your system or in the cloud
and we will introduce you to cloud
technologies using this platform called
the t-value platform developed at the
caliber bioinformatics research center
at university of haifa
as well as some of the cloud
technologies offered by other companies
like google collab github and other
resources that are going to be useful
for you to leverage as you develop your
career in bioinformatics
so here we have i'll just briefly show
you one example as you probably all know
transcriptomic data data on rna
sequencing is becoming more and more
prominent in many different areas of
research including oncology
neuroscience and other fields and
briefly you can appreciate the
simplicity of this platform because it
really organizes the information in a
logical step-by-step process and by the
way this is reflected in the coursework
that you will find on the learn portal
it also guides you using artificial
intelligence based on the data that you
upload and the information that you
would like to receive from this pipeline
so that you can eliminate the common
mistakes that people make when they try
to design these
workflows on their own
now as a result of running these
workflows you also get a clear sense of
the logic behind the analysis including
the inputs and outputs of different
methods and so once you're ready to
transition to your own independent
pipeline that you want to build on your
own now you at least understand the
logic why would i use this method and
not that method when would i try to
modify this setting or that setting and
this spans as i mentioned across many
different areas of analysis including
next generation sequencing data mass
spectroscopy structural biology as well
as many methods for data integration and
modeling machine learning and other
types of applications so all of you can
definitely go through some of these
resources the thing is once you've
created an account on the onixler
onyxlogic portal you automatically get
access to the demo level on this
bioinformatics platform after 24 hours
so